[Music]  [Applause]  what has happened in the world that  normal now passes as excellence when did  we lower our standards we are living in  an environment where people are blind  what you don't see you don't know  out of sight out of mind  [Music]  our husbands aren't coming back  Ronald  there's a lot of money  and now people want it from us  now the best thing we have going for is  is being who we are why because no one  thinks we have the balls to pull this  off  we've been this walls got you down on  your knees  if this whole thing goes wrong I want my  kids to know that I didn't just sit  there and take it I did something  in this city you reap what you sow let's  hope so  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]